-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well.
And now, if you don't mind,
we're going to get to the news.
Today was Halloween.
"Disagree," said Target.
[ Laughter ]
That's right.
Today was Halloween.
It's a great day
to ride the subway
and try to figure out
who's covered in fake blood
and who's just covered
in the regular kind.
The White House last night
hosted neighborhood families
for trick or treating.
They didn't get
that many visitors, though,
because kids know a raisin house
when they see one.
[ Laughter ]
That's right.
The White House last night
hosted local children
for trick or treating,
and Biden got
a pretty serious scare
when one of the kids
came dressed up
as his approval rating.
[ Laughter ]
"Aah!"
The website --
[ Laughs ]
You didn't have to do
the double thumbs down.
The website candystore.com
recently released
a list of the most popular candy
in the country,
including Sour Patch Kids
in New York,
Butterfingers in Massachusetts,
and Marlboro Reds in Florida.
[ Laughter, applause ]
"Yeah, you can take two, kid."
Former President Trump's sons,
Don Jr. and Eric,
and his daughter Ivanka
are set to testify
in Trump's civil fraud trial.
And for the first time
in a long time,
it's good to be Tiffany.
[ Laughter ]
The makers of Cup Noodles
announced last week
that they will introduce
a new paper cup packaging
that is microwavable,
and if that goes well,
they're thinking about
introducing noodles.
[ Laughter ]
Rock bands Lynyrd Skynyrd
and ZZ Top
yesterday announced
their upcoming tour,
and if you're excited
about this news,
you're due for a colonoscopy.
[ Laughter ]
Firefighters in Michigan
recently rescued a raccoon
that was stuck in a hole
at the bottom of a dumpster.
Although, does that
really count as a rescue?
That's like saying
you rescued Pitbull
from a VIP lounge in Miami.
That raccoon was like,
"Aah! Leave me!"
And finally,
the New Jersey Hall of Fame
over the weekend
held its induction ceremony.
So congratulations
to this tanning bed.
[ Laughter ]
And that was a monologue,
everybody.
We're off and running.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Got a fantastic show
for you tonight.
She is a talented director
and an iconic actress
who directs and stars
in "What Happens Later,"
which is in theaters
this weekend.
Meg Ryan is here tonight,
you guys!
[ Cheers and applause ]
And she is a journalist and host
of CNN's "The Source
with Kaitlan Collins."
Kaitlan Collins is joining us.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And we have
a very funny comedian
whose memoir,
"Foolish: Tales of Assimilation,
Determination, and Humiliation,"
is out now.
Sarah Cooper
is at the show tonight.
A reminder, during
the writers strike,
it was a long five months off.
We were very sad to be off.
We're very happy to be back,
but one of the things
I did during the writers
strike that I was happy with
is I started a podcast
with my brother called
"Family Trips
with the Meyers Brothers."
This is us
when we were last year,
and we -- we have interviewed
a lot of guests.
I'm going to show you
three of these are guests.
Two of them were real guests,
and one of them
hasn't been a guest yet.
You got to guess
which ones are real,
and then you have to guess
which one isn't.
Okay?
Alright. Reggie Watts.
John Oliver.
Rudy Giuliani.
Now...
[ Laughter ]
I'm not going to give it --
I'm not saying anything.
Also...
[ Chuckles ]
"I remember we used to pack in
the back of my station wagon."
Aww, such a good story.
Also, I'm going back
to New Hampshire
this Saturday night
at the SNHU Arena,
Manchester, New Hampshire.
That's where I went
to high school.
It's going to be a lot of fun.
If you want to go to a show
where my parents
are in the audience...
[ Laughter ]
...that's the one to go to.
[ Cheers and applause ]
If you have been following
the news recently,
you may have heard that "Barbie"
has been making a killing
at the box office.
A movie about a doll
made over $1 billion.
If you've been following
the news recently...
[ Light laughter ]
[ Laughter ]
We write this sketch a lot,
and one of the things
we try to do
is put a recent story
at the top,
a recent story like "Barbie."
You know, hearing things like
this always get me to thinking,
I'm getting older
and sometimes I look around
and I don't even realize
the world I'm living in anymore.
Things are changing every day,
and not always for the better.
So it's time to take a moment
to talk about how things were.
Well, they were a bit
more simple...
back in my day.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Back in my day,
a doll named Barbie
wasn't killing it
at the box office.
Poppycock!
Back in my day,
a doll named Chucky
was killing it on the screen.
[ Laughter ]
And Chucky didn't have
some complicated relationship
with a guy named Ken.
What Chucky loved
wasn't complicated at all.
It was the simplest thing
in the world.
Murder.
Stone-cold murder.
He liked taking his knife and
stabbing people in the heart.
[ Dog barks ]
You're right!
I guess that is what Barbie
does to Ken in that movie.
[ Dog barks ]
What's that?
[bleep] the patriarchy?
Alright.
If you say so, Rusty.
Back in my day,
Jada Pinkett Smith
wasn't releasin' a memoir
unveiling bombshells
about her private life.
No, back then,
Jada Pinkett Smith
didn't have what you
and I would call a private life
because of a little web series
called "Red Table Talk."
Whoever had that idea
must have had a screw loose.
[ Dog barks ]
It was her idea?
Well, I stand by what I said.
[ Laughter ]
Back in my day,
there were no bedbugs in Paris.
[ Speaking in French ]
[ Laughter ]
Back in my day, the only thing
in your bed in Paris
was your mistress...
until her husband found out,
and then you found out that
his mistress was your wife...
and the four of you have a good,
long laugh about it
while you drank
four bottles of wine
on your three-hour
lunch break --
a lunch break you earned
during a six-month-long strike.
And that is all the stereotypes
I know about France.
[ Dog barks ]
Oh, and I suppose
you smell like a bed of flowers.
[ Laughter ]
Back in my day, we weren't
spending $1,200
for a new iPhone.
Applesauce!
Back in my day,
we only spent $900 on a phone.
And as we paid for it, we said,
"I promise
this is the last phone
I'm ever going to buy from you."
And we stood by that promise
until the day
the new one came out.
And it was made of titanium.
And I don't know what's better
about a phone
made out of titanium.
I just know that
whatever material my phone
is made out of now,
I [bleep] hate!
[ Laughter ]
Get that weak-ass, non-titanium
[bleep] out of here!
Back in my day, parents weren't
bringing their kids
to trunk or treats on Halloween,
where they got candy
from the back of a parked car.
Back in my day,
if you were giving candy to kids
from out of the back
of your station wagon,
you'd face consequences
in your community...
like not being invited
to the block party
or losing your deal
as the spokesman for Subway.
[ Laughter, audience groans ]
♪♪
You told me it wasn't too soon.
[ Laughter ]
Back in my --
Is that because...?
[ Chuckles ]
Oh. Did you do it in dog years?
Yeah, in dog years it's not.
We -- You have to clarify
when we have a conversation...
Well, 'cause I'm the host
of the show,
so it's in my years.
[ Laughter ]
Back in my day, we didn't have
digital doorbell cameras
so people could leave out
a bowl of candy on Halloween
and see who's coming
to their door.
Raisinets!
Back in my day,
there was a bowl of candy
on a porch with a little sign
that said, "Please take one."
You'd do a little look around,
make sure the coast was clear,
and dump that whole damn bowl
right into your backpack.
And on the way out, you'd pass
a young father with a toddler
and a Paw Patrol costume
and you'd say, "Don't bother.
That jerk didn't
leave out any candy."
And the father would say,
"Yes, I did. This is my house."
But he couldn't catch you
because you was dressed as Ken
and you was wearing
rollerblades.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
And, yes, that was today.
Oh, now?
Now you got nothing to say?
By the way, Rusty is here today
courtesy of a waiver
from WAG-AFTRA.
[ Dog growling ]
Oh, you love that joke.
Back in my day,
we worried about --
We weren't worried, excuse me,
about AI bringing down humanity.
No way.
We were worried about
Y2K bringing down humanity.
We were worried the world
was going to shut down
at midnight of the year 2000.
And seeing what the past
23 years have been like,
maybe it did.
[ Laughter ]
Y2K, why not 2K?
Back in my day, people weren't
accusing a chess champion
of using vibrating anal beads
to cheat at chess.
[ Laughter ]
It's a true story.
Google it -- at home,
not at your work desk.
♪♪
Well, you see, back in my day,
they were accusing someone else
of this particular method
of cheating.
But let me tell you, I won that
spelling bee fair and square.
Now, you may have some follow up
questions about that story,
so check it out on
"Back in My Day Extras"
streaming on Peacock.
Back in my day,
Twitter wasn't known as X.
No, sir.
Back in my day,
if you were typing
"X" in the URL bar,
you were almost certainly
going to a porn website
filled with nasty,
disgusting stuff.
Not quite as disgusting
as what you can find on X today,
but pretty close.
[ Laughter ]
Back in my day, we weren't
getting a "Frasier" reboot.
Back in my day,
if you wanted to watch a sitcom
starring a funny white man,
you just turned on "Seinfeld"
or "Full House"
or "King of Queens"
or "NewsRadio"
or "Spin City" or "Wings"
or "The Drew Carey Show."
And if you didn't,
you turned on "Martin,"
which you probably should
have done to begin with.
[ Dog barks ]
"Damn, Gina" indeed.
Back in my day,
we weren't giving
former presidents gag orders.
Hocus POTUS!
Back in my day,
we were giving former presidents
a podcast
with Bruce Springsteen.
And let me tell you...
well, I meant to listen to it.
[ Laughter ]
Sure sounded good on paper.
Well, I'm sorry
I had to do that, everybody,
but sometimes
this grumpy old gramps
has got a couple of ghosts
and ghouls to gripe about.
This has been "Back in My Day."